hey y'all attended catch here and this
tie tuesday video we're not going to be
going over this week's data set
instead i wanted to make a series where
we basically start a project from
scratch
and complete it uh and we're going to do
this basically in three videos
um i wanted to make three parts one
where we basically go over
the project setup uh data collection and
data cleaning
my second video i'm planning on doing is
just like the feature engineering and
the modeling
and then the third part will be
basically deploying it and creating an
app using our shiny so
i thought it'd be interesting especially
since i have about 48 videos
uh since i started the entire tuesday
project so
i thought making three videos on you
know showing how to start up a project
and finish it
and then for my last video for that for
the year would be
a q a so in the description below there
will be a link to a
google sheets link so you can ask me a
question
uh for my q a video i did notice that
some of the questions were more
mostly about like video suggestions um
that's not really what the
q a video is gonna be about so i'm
mostly about like you know
about data science itself not really
what i'm planning on making
so i'm just a little heads up for
uh if you're gonna submit any questions
because i probably will not answer any
uh
video ideas uh yeah that's being said um
i wanted to create a ufc sports betting
model
so in between uh jobs when i
uh accepted a position as a data
scientist i basically had
about a month off before i started my
position so
during that month i i did some traveling
and then i also wanted to start
i all started a small little project so
i started up a ufc sports bank model and
actually in the scripts
um i did get uh pretty far into it um
last weekend i was actually organizing
it and i kept dancing the scripts so
i've already done a decent amount of
work for this project so i think
what will be good about this um video
series or this three-part series
is not running a go uh where i'm like
improv doing improv
and coding itself i'm kind of going over
these steps
and the ideas that go behind it how you
can really approach these problems when
you're starting your own
uh side project i will also say that you
guys can definitely just you know do a
uh and fork this repo uh i have a
i have the repo actually in the taiyo
tuesday project uh
so you don't have to go into my other
repos but
i'm totally fine with you guys forking
it you know building upon it and stuff
like that
i will say though if you're gonna like
you know put it
uh put out somewhere in public uh to
give me some credit um i think that's
basically it but
you do whatever you want um just uh give
me some credit
so when you're actually starting a
project the
first thing you have to do is actually
create a project
uh so i think when you're doing it you
should always create you know a little
folder that will have your project
in this case we're putting in the
tuesday repo and i'm calling it the tidy
tuesday ufc project
so i created an r project using um
rstudio
uh and that way you can set your
directory to that and you just click on
this
and it'll kind of open it up to your own
set directory
uh it'll make it like our proj that user
which
i found with uh i don't think i have
anything like classified or anything
like that
i think it's fine but i see there's any
problem with it i'll
make sure to remove it but generally
when i'm making a project or i'm
starting a project like at work
or by myself i'll generally create two
folders
one folder for my data and one folder
for my scripts
so when you're actually starting your
project you need to find a data source
and hopefully this data source isn't
easily attainable
so if it's an easy easily attainable
source then
you really want to focus on the analysis
part of it
but most most of the time you're trying
to start a project where
you want to grab the data itself either
from web scraping or
requesting through an api um in this
case it's pretty easy to get ufc data um
i went to ufcstats.com
uh you go to like events and fights i
marked completed
and then when i scroll down you can see
that there's an awl and now we have
a page where it's all of the cards of
all the ufc fights
so right now we have a bunch of links to
all these cards
and what i wanted to do is basically
scrape every fight that the ufc has ever
promoted
with all the data so right now when we
click into a card we have a
summary of all the fights if we actually
click on these like
uh cards or these individual fights on
the card we can see that we get a little
bit more
um detail in the actual fight itself so
we have you know knocked down statement
strikes significant strike percentages
um we also have you know per round
stuff like that um all the stuff we also
have like method of ko
uh method of win so kotko round one
time 117 a time format no
time limit etc so when i was looking
this
uh there's it almost falls a hierarchy
so we have a
a card a fight and then a fight detail
and with the fights we really don't want
to to me i didn't really need to
worry about scraping these individual
components because
the fight details has most of these
components so
i was finally basically ignoring this
and just using this to scrape the actual
fight links
okay um so i'm not going to go over the
actual web scraping for it
i'll definitely show you what i did for
it and kind of explained what i was
thinking about
but one of the most important things
when you're doing these types of
projects is
we know that this data is gonna be a
little dynamic
so what that means is um every month or
two
there's gonna be another card where we
would like to scrape that data
to be used in future pipelines right so
right now we know that
in on february 6 there's gonna be ufc
fight night
so we would like to scrape that card
once it finishes
um so i'm gonna look load up my data
scraping script so this is going to be
the script that's basically going to
um scrape all of the um the data
what we actually want to do is kind of
scrape you know the raw data and not do
any cleaning with it
so that way we will always have some
type of you know
backup uh for our project so
right now what i basically loaded in was
you know arvest which is the uh web
scraping
uh tidy verse the here package which
i've been using for the past few months
which is very useful
uh especially with working with
directories in r so right now like
instead of typing all of that um
directory nonsense right if i look up
right here so if i do like a school uh
folder artwork title tuesday titles and
ufc project scripts
instead i can just use here which would
do the actual main directory which will
be the title choose a ufc project
so that makes it a little bit simpler uh
when you're
trying to load in a data set or even
write a data set to your
project folders in this case we'd
probably want to write most of our stuff
to our data folder okay so
what i basically did is wrote a few
functions to scrape uh
the links so the first one is gonna be
scraping
the cards additionally i have one that
will scrape the dates
from the cards and i'll scrape uh the
fights which are like for each card we
have like 11 or 12 fights
and then using those fight links we're
going to scrape the actual summary data
which is where most of the mean potatoes
are at right because we want to scribe
each we want to scrape you know the
summary data
so the total submit submission attempts
significant strikes fighter name
etc the details so
oh you know win loss round finish etc
um i also wrote a function to basically
round by round data but in this case i
didn't actually use it
uh to for the analysis especially since
we're gonna do a model
so for me i would rather just kind of
make it a little bit simpler and just
you know instead of predict round by
round stuff or even use round by round
data just kind of keep it a little bit
simpler and keep it
on a fight level and then uh
next we're actually going to go over
like the actual scraping so
we actually remove all these little
functions and condense them
um they're pretty self-explanatory right
we have
our scraping functions that we're gonna
be using to actually scrape uh
and then uh we can actually scrape it so
i wrote this all so it's pretty pipeable
and it actually follows a hierarchy
so first we have our ufc page which is
like
the page of all the card links then we
basically scrape all the cards then
using all the cards
we scrape all the dates and then after
that we scrape all the fights from the
from that stuff right so once we have
basically
our our fight links which is based what
we want
because um that's how a granule we're
going to get
i actually set up a progress bar so that
way we can actually scrape the actual
fight data
um i'm not going to go over this yet but
i want to say that
once you actually scrape all this stuff
this this function actually takes a long
time if you're going to start from
scratch because they're going to be
essentially scraping like
i don't know a couple thousand fights
and that'll take a long time
so what i actually have is i have the
raw data that we've previously scraped
right here
we're gonna use that data basically to
say like if we've already scraped this
card
we're just going to remove that card
from our scraping queue
and then we're actually going to script
the fight so there's no card to scrape
it'll give an error
but i'm probably just going to manually
run this because there's no really set
schedule for
fights obviously fights are always gonna
happen on saturday but sometimes you
know
it's not gonna be every other saturday
if that's gonna happen so for me i'm
fine with
running it uh whenever i need to
basically update my data set which i'll
probably be running you know
maybe once a month because most fighters
aren't gonna be fighting on the same
like twice in a month so you're finally
running it basically once a month and
getting away with it
so i actually removed uh the most recent
fight which was the conor mcgregor uh
dustin poirier fight
so let's actually run this function
right here and kind of go over
uh what what i was thinking about doing
okay so we ran all this stuff and we can
see that's actually scraping the card
right and then we have it where it's
writing out
the new data set right here which is the
fight data raw
dot csv and that'll be loaded in the
future
so when we actually look at this um
see right here we can see all these um
all this stuff when we actually do a
view
there
so right here we have we can actually
look at this hierarchy where we have the
ufc page
which will be the same for all the cards
then we have the actual card
uh link which has all the fights we have
the card date
right here and then for on each card
we were scraping the fight details
and then when we see the fight details
here are the actual things that we're uh
we're grabbing so we're getting a
fighter
hit his or her knockdowns significant
strike landed
they gain attempts etc
and then it switches over to fighter two
we have that and it's basically the same
uh
metrics i just uh replaced with fighter
two
then we have the method of wand so ko
tko
uh then we have round finished time
format referee
the fighter fighter one rez and the
fighter two rez
so sorry if you haven't watched the
fight um it kind of spoiled it for you
but
uh i think you probably saw in the news
if you didn't see it
um so as you can see that data is pretty
dirty it's not great for
actual modeling but we can actually use
it um
uh to actually clean our data so right
now i'm actually going to
go and open up our cleaning our data
cleaning script
and this is where we're actually
cleaning the data
um most of it is just kind of renaming
stuff converting things into factors
um parsing dates removing redundant
things that we don't really need for the
model
so in this case we don't really need
like the page links the card link and
the fire link
we also want to like you know rename all
the fields and stuff like that
i also did a slight amount of feature
engineering so
you know i'm just creating like
percentages so like you know total
strikes landed divided by total strike
attempted etc um
so stuff like that where i was i was i
was changing a few things
um and then we have some gender stuff
where i had to do some regular
expressions
um additionally um sometimes when the
weight class was missing we i
looked it up and found that it was
usually just catch weights that were
missing
stuff like that um sometimes there were
there was no referee so i had to
remove that but in the end i don't
wasn't really planning on using the
referee itself
although i do think that would be kind
of interesting to model out like referee
bias
um and then i actually did some you know
again the same type of cleaning where
it's mostly just renaming
removing unnecessary things because i'm
basically renaming all this other stuff
and kind of sorting everything out so
really i don't want to go over all of
this code because it's really just kind
of redundant cleaning
um it's not too interesting and it's
something that everyone
has a different approach to doing just
how i wanted to do it because
you know i was going to use this data
for myself um but i will say
one of the main things i want to show
you is that we're not really
we're we're using our raw data that we
scraped but we're not actually
overwriting that data instead we have
this
you know fightdataraw.csv but after all
the cleaning we're actually creating
um our fight data which is like the
clean version of it
so that is to basically prevent anything
um from interrupting the flow
so yeah you kind of have to think of it
as like a downstream effect where
this is like our raw data that we don't
want to
uh corrupt at all and then we have our
fight data
which will be basically data we're going
to be using that it's cleaned and used
for most of the feature engineering
and modeling so now that we've already
designed
all of our um our project we kind of
have to think about
um you know how we can reproduce this
for
um you know if we want to do anything
more so i'm actually going to go back to
the uh
was it the data scraping and kind of go
over
um some of the functions now
and explain my thinking so most of these
uh i guess most of these uh html things
was
just using the combination of um
inspector get the was it the inspector
gadget thing
the uh select the selector gadget
tool and also just kind of inspecting
the html
um one of the things that i think is
good with this um
this uh um data scraping script is that
it's very
tidy um so basically i'm using um the
mapping functions to use
for all the the list of page links from
a given hierarchy of cards
we're basically using that to describe
the cards and then we're based kind of
like removing
any cards that we've already scraped
then we're also doing the general
scraping functions
um i will say that adding a progress bar
towards to
your actual scraping functions is very
useful
uh especially since uh you uh when
you're giving it to people
um such as like you guys itself um it
would definitely
cause a lot of problems where um if i
didn't have a progress bar
or you couldn't see like how many fights
have been scraped
uh people would probably cancel the
actual scraping function because the
scraping function takes a long time
so adding this really helps users
understand you know what's going
on and also just writing functions that
are
um pretty self-explanatory so none of
these car
none of these um objects are very
confusing
right we have like our ufc page which
you can kind of read like okay these are
like all the events etc
we have scrape cards which is scraping
the fight card links
and we have the anti-join using our
previous scrape cards so it says remove
cards that have already been scraped
then we have our scrape card dates and
then scrape fights from every fight card
so um that uses like again the same
functions scrape dates script bytes
finally we do the actual progress bar
and then we do
the using the fight data we actually
scrape the fight summary data
i did wrap um safely around the mapping
function
and that's because there's those when
you're especially when you're doing a
lot of web scraping
that can run into some errors where you
know it might return a null
in this case safely will kind of just
ignore it so
with that it'll kind of give you um a
better way where you know if you're
scraping you know for
4 000 bytes and then you know one of the
fights
uh return something that that your your
actual web shipping functions couldn't
really
understand it's not just going to stop
everything and you're not going to lose
all of your progress
instead it's going to continue trudging
on and you might just have one
error in one fight and that's fine
so that's basically it for this video i
know this video wasn't very interesting
because it's most about the projects but
um
we actually look at on my own repo
um what we will start focusing on which
will probably be the
most important part of this project is
the actual modeling part
so you see i have the feature entering
feature engineering and modeling done
so next week we're going to be focusing
on you know think about what type of
features you want to create for our
model
and also just what models want to use
not from an algorithmic standpoint but
on a model structure standpoint so we're
going to go over maybe like multi-headed
models
i'm figuring out like how much should we
use multiple models
to break multiple components or is it
better to just put everything together
in one single model
and it's like uh predict the outcome so
we're going to go over a lot of like
modeling frameworks and model ideas
for the next week's video which will be
very fun and i'm going to be uh
trying to finish that up probably uh
next week but with that being said i'll
see you guys next week and teddy on